what talk about Steve Harvey why because
Oh media Trump know him saying that
Asian men are undateable what is it yeah
I mean see what happens when you meet
with Trump bread spam yeah a lot of
people believe and this is a cultural
thing it's an America merican cultural
thing where they believe that we're not
hands or sex symbols males the women I
have always you know Asian women have
always been like fetishized and put on a
pedestal but Asia oh right by other
races yes yeah by whites you know
generally mm-hm and um I'll give you an
example like when that relationships
between steel we've talked about on the
podcast Steven's relationship in the
show Walking Dead with that white chick
magnet with Maggie right and then Ryan
Seacrest said what he said
Maggie's kind of Asian though she's
white completely yes actress you know
you know one of those guys that if a
white chick is dating asian guy youth a
location you can accept it so in your
head your eyes aren't a little no
nothing Asian about or do yeah sixty
Martin's kind of black know what the
real world is is David Boies uh David
Boies black because dating you know yeah
you know no she's not Asian doing baby
boys did see Chris basically said that
you know it doesn't walk it doesn't
really it wouldn't really have he
doesn't bite in the apocalypse only time
you could buy
you could buy any time but if you if you
are a skeptic yeah yeah yeah when
there's 12 guys left
yeah the odds are yes you know he's like
I see her dating our dad no but you know
even though Ryan Secrets probably see
she would probably rub the China's
before she dated like I'll go lesbian I
mean such some white dudes they can't
accept it but you know Asian dudes that
pull white chicks right I was one of
them yeah there you go
yeah I mean we've he's done it what what
did yeah why did you just [ __ ] her
how did we are doing and we're gonna
[ __ ] talk about that in a second okay
come on he wrote a book on how to date a
white woman a practical guy for Asian
men steve harty he didn't write that I
think someone else did and he was like
talked about it yeah and he was like if
that was a book or it would be one page
long do you date Asian men and their
response would be no and he went on to
say oh he said you like Asian man I
don't even like Chinese food he said I
don't eat what I can't pronounce
sometimes Steve Harvey like does this
there's this way if you just say
ignorant things it sounds funny and
that's yeah yeah even when he was on
family feud which I watched his bloopers
and I think he's very funny it's very
funny on Spanish food and some of the
jokes are like sometimes a little like
you know hacking but he has to improvise
within you know a clean way right so I I
forgive him for that so he is a comedian
so I'm gonna give him that right but
aside from the him there is a lot of
people that believe that and it's it's
got to stop
well let me ask you a question yeah like
do Asian dudes go after other races yeah
yeah last night I did the improv and it
and a tiger river fan I was sitting the
front row
Asian dude was dating a white girl I see
it in my shows also happens so it may be
in my show there did they just come out
all right but it's like you know I see
it all the time but what bothers me
about about that is that I have Asian
female friends who are offended by the
fact who don't like the fact that Asian
men see dating a white woman as a step
above dating them oh boy
you say that a lot oh you won the
lottery you're dating a white woman not
in the lottery in terms of like what you
got it's in terms of like socially right
like it's because it's such a it's a
little harder this happens in the black
community right it's a little harder I
feel the same way so it's there is a
sense of like oh I mean I'm killing big
game here I just shoot like coyotes in
our dinosaur back in time yeah there is
a sense of that like when you when I
when I was 24 and I was with Jennifer
field and she was this girl that lived
by the beach and he had like dolphin
tattoos was just so [ __ ] gross but I
I was eating or [ __ ] I was in the
closet because her mom was home
oh so I was eating her [ __ ] in the
closet yeah crazy and but and I looked
at her like a little because I could see
through that you know that the darkness
her face or my face it's the
unlikeliness that makes it feel like
again maybe this is real good sitting
like four months later we're gone done
sir Larry yeah
because her in size wasn't right with my
insides not in terms of organs [ __ ] I'm
talking about like our beliefs and our
values and
laughs it sound like some anatomical it
sounded physical it's not but was it we
were okay it wasn't physical of dog okay
[Music]